the summer is when parents have to be
particularly alert to the dangers of
drowning deaths children younger than 5
are among the most likely to die in
pools the Consumer Product Safety
Commission says nearly 70% of child
deaths happen when they're not expected
to be in the water
kids often find ways to slip away from
adults Olympic ski racing champion bode
miller and his wife Morgan lost their 19
month old daughter Emmy in June now
they're trying to prevent other families
from experiencing the same tragedy she
would walk into over the room and
everyone would want enough who is this
little blond-haired blue-eyed girl who
just is this massive ball of energy and
light and love you couldn't believe that
she had that balance of sort of
personality and patience and all the
things that you would want Emmy was
playing at a neighbor's house when the
19 month old slipped out unseen fell
into their pool and drowned when they
open the door and she was floating
plates facedown in the pool every time I
close my eyes it great to go to sleep
replays in my head but it it happens so
fast on the same day Nicole Hughes lost
her three-year-old son Levi in a similar
drowning accident like Emmy Levi also
found his way outside to a pool when I
look at pictures of him it's so
overwhelming to think I will not any new
pictures Evan ever now the two moms
bonded by tragedy are uniting with water
safety advocates to prevent these
drownings a lot of parents have reached
out to me saying like I put my child
down for now and that was the last I saw
our child alive
since Emmys death bodis been in the
water with his three year old son Nash
as he learns self rescue techniques not
just our kids but our friends have
brought their kids over and we've kind
of been attacking it as a group and I
think it's been it's been really
eye-opening to see I opening for them
and they hope for others as they push
for change I cannot let his death have
been in vain I can I have to fight like
hell to do everything for all of us to
fight so that no one else experiences
this Bodhi and Morgan Miller and Nicole
Hughes join us now also with us is dr.
Ben Hoffman from the American Academy of
Pediatrics good morning to all of you
and thank you so much for joining us and
we've spoken on the phone but again we
are so sorry for what's happened to you
bori let me ask you I mean what do you
hope people will learn by sharing your
story your family's tragedy yeah I hope
people sort of raise the awareness of
what the danger is I think people have a
natural awareness of water dangers I
mean as a human being we know it's not
our natural element but there are
specific things that just that knowledge
alone is a really powerful tool and I
think that knowledge is not common
practice right now that you know these
drownings are happening not during swim
time I think as a parent those little
tidbits of knowledge are things that we
can share with each other and once it
becomes you know something that
everyone's aware of we can really
prevent these these kind of tragedies
and that's at the end of the day you
know what happened to us is is horrible
for us and I think a lot of people
shared our pain and that but we want to
try to make it not happen other people
and Morgan and Nicole you both told me
separately that you couldn't have done
this without the other that you couldn't
be speaking out with the out the other
to do Bodhi said that you're motivated
by emotion I'm I'm so touched by that
and what do you say to people that say
this could never happen to me this is
what I think is so important for people
to understand how quickly this can
happen you
and every time I would read as a parent
you know I would read all these stories
and I automatically always look for the
loophole you know how okay well this
isn't me because they thought about this
isn't they were good okay you know where
I would never let that happen okay not
me this tragedies not mine yeah but it
actually does it really happens and I
mean we are involved attentive parents
who loved our children we love our
children and keep them safe so no one is
tragedy does not play fair I mean and
just to make sure you are aware at all
times and that you spread that knowledge
to your friends as well so then this
becomes a village mentality truly that
we are always all looking out for each
other's kids and spreading this
awareness like we do in other things
where the car seats and whether it with
everything else that we share with you
know tragedy is not fair I like that
line and you and Morgan you had said
that you know people don't understand a
how quickly this could happen even to
the most vigilant parent and have you
had many people coming up to you saying
this almost happened to me or this
happened to me or because of you this
didn't happen to me hundreds of people
have reached out to us but I think
touching briefly on what Nicole was
saying is I think a lot of parents feel
like it's not going to happen to them
because they think it's gonna happen
during swim times when they're out there
watching their children there's all
these people but one of the most
surprising things that we've learned is
the times that this truly is an issue
and how many parents have reached out to
us and said I put my child down for a
nap
that was the last time I saw my child
alive and understanding that when even
though you're not by the pool that if
you don't have that visual stimulant of
water it's almost like out of sight out
of mind but understanding that just
putting your child down for a nap like
they are curious they are brilliant
amazing little people and they can find
ways outside outdoors out doggy doors
out windows so really being aware that
even though you're not swimming it can
still happen doctor often I think I
think so many of us are surprised by
this statistic that drowning is the
second leading cause of death for
children 1 to 4 why is it we're not
aware of this so it's actually the
leading cause of another one yes
Oh death for kids under the age of four
I think some of it has to do with risk
perception and just the fact that we
don't talk about it a lot it happens
what does that mean reception we don't
perceive it as a risk yes that that it
because we're around water a lot that
people don't recognize the the constant
threat that it represents it really
comes down to the fact that you can't
drown proof a child and that we need to
be thinking about ways that we can get
the word out and educate we need to
think about policies and ways we can
enforce those and we need to think about
engineering solutions so that we can
automatically protect kids and families
so that we don't have to think about it
I think Morgan and Nicole everything
I've learned about the two of you is not
only your bond but you are United and
trying to make a change you want you
don't want anybody else to have to go
through what you want and so you have a
specific action plan what do you want
help from doctors nurses others what do
you want them to do well one of the
things that really inspires us was quote
that we read that when women moms come
together parents come together anything
can be accomplished and so we are really
really hoping that people are gonna get
involved and they're gonna be other moms
babysitter's nannies grandparents
teachers that are gonna help us spread
the word so not just relying on ap and
pediatricians but having this just be a
change in society a change in our
mindset to have this be a conversation
that's exactly what happened with
Mothers Against Drunk drivers exactly
what happened and led to a change it was
a game changer for everybody
mothers if that's exactly what happened
you met each other through this tragedy
what has what has that support the
support you've given each other meant to
have to have you know and it's horrible
because we would not have met without
losing our babies so it obviously
there's that just too horrific part of
it but this goodness this to be able to
have this connection to have this
reminder of the goodness that is still
in the world
through this relationship through this
friendship with both of them and to have
is is truly it's been a lifeline I mean
I can't imagine not only this this
movement this conversation that work
that we're starting about about drowning
prevention but from a grief standpoint
and just knowing that we are going to
survive this one second out of time and
even the moments that we don't we know
that it's just a moment and that we I
don't know how but we usually know when
the other person is feeling down in
grief is such an individual process that
somehow we've been on the same page for
most of this journey which has been
inspiring and amazing to be able to have
someone besides obviously our spouses
removing the stigma is part of changing
the conversation it's like we have
people come up to us who it's really
hard to address they don't know what to
say and they don't want to cause you
more pain and they don't want to you
know dodge around the subject the fact
is breaking that stigma and making it a
conversation that you can't have with
parents who have you know unfortunately
experienced at firsthand is I think one
of those really important steps and it
helps to have people who there is no
stigma there because they've gone
through it as well even though they're
at different phases or whatever it's an
open conversation where you know that
you know laughing and joking is not
doesn't mean it's gone and it doesn't
mean it's just part of our lives now so
how do you have Morgan Miller Nicole
Hughes dr. Ben Hoffman thank you all for
being here this morning on this just
critical subject